so thank you very much cynthia for
coming and please take it away thank you
thank you very much hopefully everyone
can hear me
um great
it's a very nice
introduction
um
it's good to have
to be slow in the technology
to stretch it out
um yeah so i'm so i'm a mathematician so
this will be a much more theoretical
theory talk than than the one uh before
um it's a it's a real honor to to come
and speak at this event and i i feel
like it's done a really great
uh showcase of how
uh how open and how broad the research
in theoretical computer science is um
so i'm going to talk about
some
some research that i got into during a
semester at the at the simon's program
um this is joint work with nima inari
liu shayanov
and and jun wong
please feel free to ask questions uh at
any point
um
[Music]
so
uh so for me
um this this really started in fall 2017
um when there was a a very large uh
so both both programs at the simons
institute uh were the same and they were
on bridging continuous and discrete
optimization
um so there was a huge number of people
there that semester and at the same time
i'm sorry to advertise also another
institute but in this case it was really
a case of synergy there was also an msri
in berkeley there was a program on
geometric and topological combinatorics
and so you had a lot of people all in
the same place thinking about
some of the same objects from very
different
viewpoints um
and it was really amazing
and i think some of the the stuff i'm
going to talk about today
you know wouldn't happened or wouldn't
have happened as quickly as without um
all of these people being in the same
place
and really without the simons institute
um and
uh
some of the
some of the work in this was was
followed up on two years later uh on a
program of the geometry of polynomials
and implications for approximation
algorithms
um in computer science
um
so in terms of
uh content
i wanted to to warm up
uh to the geometry of polynomials
with a simple example the geometry of
polynomials is using
properties of real polynomials as
functions to try and understand and
study various algorithms and
combinatorial structures
so as a warm-up
i want to just consider
univariate polynomials
um
with real coefficients having the
special property that all of their roots
are real
um
so a polynomial degree d will have d
roots counted with multiplicity i want
all of those to be real numbers
um
and these polynomials uh
appear in a lot of natural places and
have a lot of nice consequence
um
one nice consequence of
of such a property of real rootedness of
polynomials
is that if you have a
is something called newton's
inequalities which is a
inequalities on the coefficients of
those polynomials you get some
information about the just about the
shape
of the
of the coefficients um so if you have a
real rooted polynomial and all of its
coefficients are non-negative
um then this sequence of coefficients is
what's called ultralog concave so has
has a shape related to the binomial
coefficients
another consequence
is
another type of log concavity
which is
log concavity as a function
so you can check just by a calculation
that if you have a real rooted
univariate polynomial with non-negative
coefficients
um and then you do the calculus exercise
then as a as a function on the positive
real line it is log concave the second
derivative of the log is is negative
um
and and both of these as hopefully will
be constant by the end of the talk are
interesting uh and useful um
consequences that one gets from knowing
something about
some polynomial
i realize i have no clock up here so
maybe you can warn me you'll feel
dragged me off there great um
so this seems
like a toy example but actually one can
derive quite a lot um starting from this
toy example and going forwards
um
there are multivariate versions of this
uh feel free to ignore the details but
if you have a multivariate polynomial we
call it stable
if it has no zeros in the in the product
of the upper half plane so all of whose
imaginary parts are
are positive
this is something that was developed in
in solutions of partial differential
equations and then it has appeared in
lots of different areas of mathematics
and been useful since then
um
and
uh
one you know sort of canonical example
of this is taking a determinant of a
linear matrix
with
where the the coefficients of the
variables are positive semi-definite
matrices
um the running example
my running example for today is a
special case of this
uh which is going to be the the
generating polynomial for the spanning
trees of a graph
so if you take a a graph
like this one and you have n edges where
n is five
there's some collection of spanning
trees which i'm going to consider as
subsets of the edges
that reach every vertex and have no
cycles
and you could write down a polynomial
here in five variables that corresponds
to this which is just to every spanning
tree you associate the product of the
corresponding monomial so for example 1
2 3 gets x1 x2 x3 and you sum up all
over
them and by a weighted version of the
matrix tree theorem this is actually a
determinant of exactly this form and so
this polynomial has this property this
thing we're associating to a
combinatorial object
this polynomial has this complex
analytic property of having no zeros in
some portion of the complex plane
um
okay which you know could just be nice
but turns out to to be useful and tell
us and can tell us something about for
example the spanning trees of the graph
that's the point
so
these have appeared in various ways in
theoretical computer science
this is not a complete list this is at
least hopefully a representative sample
so for example in the
in the late
[Music]
1990s early 2000s
these were
used as a theoretical tool for
various types of convex optimization
problems that generalize linear
programming and semi-definite
programming
um
so this was sort of pioneered by goler
and
and and and jim renegar really sort of
um
pushed the theory to the to the state of
the art
um where to such a polynomial one can
associate a convex cone and do linear
optimization over this convex cone very
quickly
and the
the feature that makes these algorithms
work well is exactly this real
rootedness property which is somewhat
remarkable
um
in
in 2013
in a series of papers uh adam marcus dan
spielman and kelsey vestava used stable
polynomials to open to answer some
long-standing open questions and
operator theory and also combinatorics
using what's called interlacing families
um particularly they solved what's
called the carson singer conjecture and
uh
and gave methods for constructing
ramanujan graphs
and again one of the
things underlying this work was a study
of real rooted polynomials and their
multivariate generalization
um
and then one of the other
things that was developing around the
same time
um was applications in discrete uh
understanding discrete probability
distributions
um counting uh and sampling from
discrete distributions and this notion
of negative dependence
lena garvitz
used stable polynomials uh in to to
bound
um
associated to the permanent of a matrix
to to resolve something called the van
der waals conjecture about the permanent
of a doubly stochastic matrix
um
and then people also started using these
in particular some of my co-authors
around the same time um
to
to develop algorithms for sampling from
discrete probability distributions that
one would associate to these polynomials
namely the coefficients of these
polynomials
um
and and part of the machinery
surrounding this
uh is is in this beautiful paper by
bertia brendan and lingett um that
these this class of polynomials uh
captures
uh very beautifully a notion of negative
dependence and is very and one can use
sort of this theory of polynomials
uh to really understand operations on
probability distributions that are
preserved under this
and so because we understand a lot about
polynomials we can then translate that
into many things about uh
probability distributions
um and so this was uh
what was going on around 2017
and so when we had all of these many uh
people here including many of the people
on this list
uh we had a reading group on uh stable
polynomials and their various
appearances
where people from these different groups
started talking to each other and trying
to understand
um
what everyone was doing
um
and that is and you know for a whole
semester we did this while many well
many other things were going on in
berkeley um and this and this really
comes out
from that
so just as an example you can throw some
i can sneak some math in
so
one of the
the properties of stable polynomials
um
is
uh that a a certain
other polynomial that one can get from
applying differential operators
is is non-negative
um and for example if you
evaluate
this
this function here at a point namely the
all ones vector it tells you something
actually about the probabilities
of various
elements appearing in a randomly chosen
subset so the setup is you have you're
choosing a random subset of the numbers
one through n
and you have maybe your two favorite
elements i and j and you want to
understand what's the likelihood that
they show up and how those likelihoods
relate to each other
and
what this says
is that if your distribution
corresponded to a polynomial with this
this property
then
those probabilities that your two
favorite elements uh show up um
it's less likely that they both show up
than it would be if they're independent
uh so for example if we
take this graph and we choose a spanning
tree of this graph uniformly at random
there's eight of them
um
and our two favorite edges are one and
two then the probability that both
show up is two out of eight which is
less than the probability the product of
the probabilities that they each show up
individually
and so this is this is negative
dependence
um and it's a property that uh
it also is
is desirable for a lot of sampling
algorithms is that it tends to
if you sample from distributions with
this property it tends to increase the
diversity of your solutions so this is
it's a nice property to work with one
gets it from guarantees of it from
stability and it's desirable for various
sampling applications
if you want to try and understand what
types of combinatorial objects you can
use this on
um
uh one of the constraints that one
finds fairly quickly is that these
i'm maybe lying a little bit but uh that
these are very closely related to
combinatorial objects called metroids
which are another classical object and
sort of combinatorial optimization
um
so on a relatively high level
metroids are
an attempt to a combinatorial attempt to
model versions of independence
um this includes so the sort of
fundamental examples are linear
independence of vectors in a vector
space
and cyclic independence of edges in a
graph
formally
a matrix
one can formulate them lots of different
ways one way is that they're
you have a ground set
say the numbers one through n or the
edges in a graph and you are interested
in a collection of subsets with some
property
um
like the spanning trees of the graph
where if you have two such
such subsets and you have an element
that's in one
that's not in the other you can make an
exchange
and the result is also an element of
your collection so i have this exchange
property
as do for example the spanning trees of
the connected graph
and this exchange property guarantees
that for example if you want to use the
greedy algorithm
to find your favorite such
object that you will always succeed
so for example
finding the min cost spanning tree in a
graph is an example of something that
you can solve using a greedy algorithm
and that's exactly because the spanning
truths of the graph form the bases of a
matrix
um and
there's lots of different combinatorial
objects
you can associate to metroids i just
wanted to list
some of them feel free to ignore this if
you
like um but the so the one thing you can
associate to it is a simplicial complex
um which is a collection of subsets
that's closed under inclusion um
like this one or you know as as showed
up in a reit dinner's talk
like a graph but where we allow
subsets of more than two things
and another very natural object to
associate to two metroids is a polytope
which is going to be the convex hull of
a bunch of indicator vectors of these
subsets
um
and
some so metroids
have been around for a long time um but
recently especially in combinatorics and
algebraic combinatorics
there have been some breakthroughs
on the theory of of metroids and in
particular one of the big breakthroughs
that happened was in 2015
um where crema proscito jinhu and eric
katz
wrote a
a beautiful long intense paper on what's
called the hodge theory for
combinatorial geometries combinatorial
geometries is another word for me joints
where they used techniques from
from algebraic geometry to associate
complicated rings to these combinatorial
objects and use them
to to get interesting consequences
um
in particular uh you know something
about the the face numbers of this
independence complex
um and in particular
uh one october morning in the fall of
2017 jinha came
to msri and gave a talk on this work and
in particular it's very small uh but the
talk that he gave was on negative
correlation and the hard dream of
relations
um
in which he he discussed applications of
this
uh this theory to negative correlation
um which is related to negative
dependence in matrix
and so this was really the
um this was very closely related to
things that were already going down uh
going on down the hill the simons
institute um and and started off this
project that of using using this theory
to
to develop um implications for for
sampling and counting in in matrix
and
and and as with
stable polynomials the
the useful thing to do turned out to be
associ to associate a class of
polynomials with some property with some
functional property uh two combinatorial
objects and use those functional
properties to say something about this
distribution you're interested in
um
the the functional property that that
came out of this work is is log
concavity
um
[Music]
so the the property of interest for some
polynomial uh with real coefficients
um let's say non-negative
uh is that as a function on the positive
origin log of f is concave that's
negative semi-definite hash
okay that's something
um
and stable polynomials one can check
just like for the univariate example
have this property so we get all of the
things we had before
um
we get a lot of the same consequences as
we had before so these were studied by
leona garvitz who showed that um log
concavity of polynomials again gives you
things like newton's inequalities so it
tells you about the shape
of your your coefficients
um
and using this theory of representation
cats uh we were able to show that
actually the if you take any metroid
whatsoever and you look at the basis
generating polynomial just like we had
for spanning trees of this graph before
that this polynomial has this property
of being log concave as a function on
the positive word
um around the same time many people were
trying to simplify this complicated um
uh theory of of er procedure and katson
particularly peter brendan and jinha
also developed an equivalent class of
polynomials they called varencian
polynomials with a lot of the same
applications
and same connections
um
how do you have time
so i should have brought a
okay
well we'll see um
five minutes left
okay
let's uh skip some stuff
um
so
uh so one consequence
well okay the
high level
of of some slide is if you actually
write down the consequences for log
concavity what ends up being important
are the the second largest eigenvalues
of some matrix one can translate um
translate this
just by again the multivariate formula
for what it means to be log concave into
something about
second largest eigenvalues of some some
matrices uh given by your combinatorial
object
um
one one consequence of this just is that
one can recover newton's inequalities
but for independent sets of metroids
um so for example
if i look at uh
all of the forests in a graph acyclic
subsets of edges and and order them
count the number with each number of
edges this sequence
divided by the binomial coefficients is
going to form a log concave
sequence is going to satisfy all of
these inequalities
that is one one consequence of this and
comes out from the log concavity of
a polynomial associated to these these
independent sets
one of the other
very surprising
connections that happened with
with this class of functions was
actually a connection to
a rit diner's talk yesterday on on
what's called high dimensional expanders
random walks on faces of a simplicial
complex
which i'm i'm not going to go into too
much of the details on
but so this this builds on a long line
of work that some of which we saw uh in
the talk yesterday
on high dimensional expanders
um
and
at a at a high level
um
what this is is that we're going to be
walking around on subsets of elements
of a given size
and we're going to be walking around in
a fairly natural way if we have some
subset like these blue dots among
the seven dots
we can drop an element with some
probability
to get three and then add one back in
with some probability um and if we take
two steps of this walk we get back to
something of the original size
and
so we can consider this as a random walk
on for example subsets of size four of
my seven dots
um
[Music]
and similarly if i
started at the bottom of this picture
start with something with three elements
and added something in with some
probability
and then deleted one again then i would
go from something with three elements to
something of three elements
and so i would also get a random walk
on these subsets of size one less um and
part of the remarkable theory about this
work is so we get some we get some
random walks on these sets this way
um and we might have many different
levels in this picture might have
subsets of many different sizes
um and the remarkable part of this
theory is that one can
understand one can bound eigenvalues of
transition matrices from these walks
building up from small pieces and relate
them all together
um
[Music]
so
uh so in particular
um
work by kaufman and openhein showed that
you can bound the eigenvalues of the
giant random walk on the largest subsets
which could be quite large and choose d
in terms of the eigenvalues of walks on
just lengths of this simplicial complex
which one should think of as small local
pieces of this simplicial complex
they call these lambda local spectral
expanders
um because you're bounding spectral
because you're bounding eigenvalues
of transition matrices and local because
you're doing that on small pieces of
your simplicial complex
and they show that you can
yeah the theorem is that you can use
very local information to get global
bounds on transition times
um
and one one piece of the story i'm still
sort of surprised by is that uh when we
were understanding and part of the story
of of showing log concavity of matrix
polynomials was uh characterizing
problem polynomials with this property
and it turned out to to match exactly
um with the characterization um that
they give
so in fact the independence complex of
any metroid is a zero local spectral
expander so satisfies this condition
um and in fact one can use that to show
so so many things but in particular for
example that the edge graph
um of the
zero one type i told you up before has
certain expansion expansion at least one
um
[Music]
uh yeah okay
um
so this
this has several consequences maybe i'll
run one run through them
and not worry too much about the details
um
but so
so consequences of this include
that
the the bases of a metroid um for
example spanning trees of a of a graph
um one can bound the mixing time of this
random walk that you get uh on them
uh in terms of of the rank and the
number of elements
uh this has been improved since then and
now the pound is down to
o of r log r
um
these bounds uh are about the mixing
time of random walk and so in particular
doesn't say anything about the
complexity of taking a
a step
um
but if you
run this for example um to sample a
spanning tree of a graph uh
approximately uniformly at random
this gives
as far as i know this gives one of the
best running times for
for sampling spanning trees from graphs
so just to since it's been a lot of
details for example if we wanted to
here's a grid
graph if we wanted to sample spanning
trees the algorithm
[Music]
is to to add an edge rather than delete
one
and then
find the set of edges that we could
delete to get back to a spanning tree
which is a cycle and then delete one
and keep going and so what this does is
this defines a random walk in the space
of spanning trees
um and the guarantee is that this random
walk
mixes quickly
and so if you wanted a random spanning
tree you could run this for some number
of iterations and then
at the end you have something that's
about unicorn
okay um so since then
there's been a lot of work i apologize
for the incomplete list
but there's been a lot of work on
understanding
other
properties of distributions and
polynomials that will have algorithmic
implications for sampling like this
um
so spectral yeah there's a list for
those of you who are interested
um but i think it's been a very fruitful
connection between
uh
blow in mathematics like combinatorics
and convex analysis
um and people in in theoretical computer
science with uh with sampling algorithms
um
and i think there's
so we sort of this this story uh was
really one about metroids and i think
moving forward there's we're going to
see what else what other sort of
combinatorial objects um this theory can
can tackle um so i will stop there and
thanks beard
[Applause]
see the amount of work that has come up
in such a short amount of time are there
any questions
i think everybody's ready for lunch for
a break thank you very much
[Music]
thank you